[Music]
cellular signaling is a complex system
of communication that governs all basic
activities of the cell
there are no cells that don't do
signaling bacteria and eukaryotic cells
may do signaling slightly differently
but they still do have an integrated
correlated system that's responsible for
triggering functions of the cell through
a series of discrete steps
protein signaling can be dissected into
three basic steps
it starts with the receivable of a
signal then transduction of the signal
and finally a response in the first step
in the process
there's a build up of a concentration of
a signal or ligand
it occupies the receptors on the surface
of the cell and in some cases
inside the cell upon binding of the
ligand to the receptor
it may cause the conformational changes
of the receptor and trigger the signal
to be transduced from extracellular to
intracellular
followed by a response there are a few
characteristics of all cell signal
transduction
first is the specificity of the
signaling molecule
the most important thing about the
signal is that the signal which
binds to a receptor in a cell membrane
is specific for a particular receptor
and the different signal won't bind to
the same receptor
this is achieved by high affinity
protein protein interactions such as
hydrogen bonding
electrostatic interactions non-covalent
interactions and etc
so that a low concentration of the
signal molecule is efficient for binding
to the receptor to trigger the function
the next characteristic is amplification
very commonly a cell might have a
response that's just the result of a
single molecule binding a single
receptor
however if the cell wants a large
response for example
the cell might want to make a lot of atp
or want to replicate the whole genome
it will need some kind of amplification
where it can turn up the volume of the
signal rapidly
so frequently in signaling pathways the
cell will go through a cascade of
reactions where the signal might affect
an enzyme
once the cell make that enzyme active it
might work on many many copies of
another enzyme
and then each of those may work on even
more copies
at some point a single signaling
molecule can result in the cascade of a
reaction
similar to a waterfall coming from just
a single molecule of water
the cell will get a large increase in
signal as a result of amplification
[Music]
the next feature or characteristic of
signaling is feedback
once enough response is achieved the
cell needs to stop the signaling process
negative feedback loop provides a
mechanism to slow down some of those
steps that are involved in amplification
so that the pathway is turned on for a
prescribed amount of time
finally the other component of a
signaling network is integration
if we look at a signaling pathway all
these signaling steps are not
single for example in the signal
transduction that regulate apoptosis
and cell proliferation there might be
just a single signal that is being
received
but other components may have crosstalk
within one pathway
this can set off the different component
in the pathway either amplifying or
turning down a particular signaling
similar to an electrical circuit the
signal can trigger not just a single
pathway
but a network of pathway interacts and
communicate with each other to amplify
signals or turn down signals
hence integration is an important part
of signaling because you will often be
dealing with the integrated function of
a number of pathways to get a particular
response
and that actually ends up being one of
the situations where sometimes a
particular enzyme may look like a
perfect target for a therapeutic agent
but if you don't take into account the
integration steps instead of dealing
with a single pathway
you may be dealing with crosstalk with a
lot of other pathways
what's more important is that in a cell
there is always compensation from other
pathways which might nullify the
therapeutics response that you wanted
there are many types of signaling
molecules
they may be small molecules for example
an amino acid or a phospholipid
alternatively they may be proteins like
hormone or cytokine
they may be carbohydrates they might
take different forms in terms of their
molecular structure
but we tend to describe signals by where
they come from
an autocrine signal is a signal that may
come from a cell but it is signaling to
itself
it may produce a component that is
released through a secretory pathway
and stays in the vicinity of the cell it
is like a self-signaling
paracrine signaling normally occur where
the signaling molecule is produced by a
neighboring cell
endocrine is usually produced by cells
from a distance
such as from other tissues or organs and
coming through the circulatory system
and finally juxtacrine is the only one
that is a little odd
the signaling is actually coming from
direct physical contact between two
cells
so it is not self-signaling within a
cell
it is also not something secreted by
another a cell
it is a signal that triggered through
physical contact